pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche cher et
piqué au lieu ces derniers jours vous
avez posé beaucoup de questions sur la
voile et le vendée globe pour les
réponses
embarquement immédiat happy aimerait
savoir quelle nourriture à embarquer et
samantha pour tenir pendant les 90 jours
de course alors samantha a de quoi tenir
jusqu'à la fin janvier début février
même si on espère qu'elles arrivent
avant blanc principalement de la
nourriture lyophilisée et sous vide des
repart qui ont été calculés au plus
juste car sur un bateau l'ennemi c'est
le poids la skipper à l'autre cette
nourriture et les produits d'hygiène
représente entre 120 et 180 et kg alors
pour info il faut savoir que ces menus
ont été élaborés très longtemps à
l'avancé car le vendée globe est une
épreuve physique cercle il faut pas
alourdir le bateau mais il faut aussi
rechargé les batteries juste pour vous
donner une idée en temps normal un
adulte qui fait peu d'exercice
sommes-nous en ce moment dépenses 2007
100 kcal si c'est un homme un peu plus
de 2006 est une femme en fonction de
l'endroit où elle va se retrouver sur le
globe de l'état de la mer donc de son
activité physique
samantha pour à brûler jusqu'à 5000
calories 5000 kcal par jour à ce tarif
là je ne sais pas si la dinde aux
marrons et ont même eu une question de
vincent le mardi jamie quel poids peut
peser un tel bateau est bien le bateau
l'initiative coeur fait partie de la
classe imoca internacional mon oreille
open class association un monocoque dont
la longueur est limitée à 60 pieds soit
18 mètres 28 pour vous donner une idée
le black pearl célèbre
navire jack sparrow est trois fois plus
grands sont au point le bateau de
samantha ted 7 8 tonnes aviva toi un peu
plus que le poids d'un éléphant
d'afrique
mais ces voiles sont beaucoup plus
grandes
shadow fight 22-22 ça doit être le code
du département les côtes d'armor
aimerait savoir si le vendée globe passe
par le point donné le poids des mots a
été nommée ainsi en référence au héros
de vingt mille lieues sous les mers de
jules verne c'est le point en mer le
plus éloigné des côtes de leur fille
nahla a déjà répondu à shadow fight sur
youtube pour ceux qui n'auraient pas vu
sa réponse je vous l'a dit le poids des
mots se trouve dans l'océan pacifique
étant donné que le vendée globe se
déroule dans l'océan atlantique et
l'océan austral
eh bien non cette course ne passe pas
par le point les mots allez une dernière
info nemo correspond parfaitement à ce
point en latin ce terme signifie
personne est dans les 22 millions de
kilomètres carrés qui entoure ce point
bien effectivement il n'y a personne
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus
merci les épis curieux pour les plus
gourmands en voici d'autres et pour ne
rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche